um and uh we did alec baldwin's podcast
uh on the patreon
we talked a little bit about that a
charming engaging fellow who reached out
and had me on honored
to be on the alec baldwin podcast at
such an important time
to show solidarity
with a long island legend
uh alec baldwin truly because he's being
attacked
he's being there it's a pylon
and it is
cancel culture
that is i believe what he believes it is
and
i'm taking his word for it
he did have an incident
what are you gonna do
this is a
the world is complex
i don't think you could say
that the guy
wanted
what happened
to have happened
he was on set
somebody put a bullet in a gun
he shot a gun
a woman lost her life
this is not
anybody's
goal
this wasn't anybody's goal
this was something that happened now you
might say why is he back to podcasting
so quickly or working but he's got to
work
he's gotta work
what's he gonna do
he's probably facing a lot of lawsuits
i don't think he'll be charged
criminally but there's probably some
lawsuits
and he may have to pay some money
so he's gonna work
and we talk about that he has me on his
show and it comes out and we'll see
i don't always agree with what alec
baldwin does i seldom do
you know i mean he behaves in
some interesting ways but he is a
charming
engaging
fun guy
and in a world where we've
lost fun
uh
he's fun
he's a lot of fun
there's
many opinions about him and his
activities
but one thing he is
is a good
time
and that'll come out i don't know when
it'll come out we don't know no one
knows and
hopefully uh his situation gets
straightened out
and everybody can move on because it's a
tragedy and a woman lost her life and
you know
you know it's um
[Music]
bad